good evening all tilt that down a little
bit more had it semi straight not super
crooked I thought it was gonna be all
happy with that I'm like ah that's a
little too much clearance over my head
so let's sort that out okay get this go
and get that going this that and the
other Hey
evening Walt ah
hi there Cain how are we today
um I'm okay
bit of a mixed day all things considered
probably captain doing all right
is this the reboot of a long stream
actually it's worth clarifying um the
sort of what's been on my mind and like
I don't know how much this thing's gonna
stay on topic I suppose about as much as
any live stream ever stays on topic but
um what's what sort of been in my mind
lately is that reboots seem to lately
have been replaced by revivals
so rather than rebooting the old thing
we just bring it back and continue from
wherever it left off which is an
interesting shift versus you know what
what it used to be for a while
hey there Casteel ever heard the song 99
luftballons well yes I am I am old
enough to be familiar with that song oh
I really am getting on that okay I have
my my 20th high school reunion next year
oh boy um so you know just sort of
what's gotten me thinking about this in
general so like some of the properties
that this has happened to lately
obviously the Dark Crystal just came out
the new series on Netflix
we had the Halloween thing that like
disregarded every sequel ago and only
went off the first one there's been talk
of doing something similar with
alien the new Terminator movie that
comes out this year is a sequel to
Terminator 2 and it's disregarding the
other ones Mad Max fury road was in many
ways kind of a revival they did it with
Roseanne they did it with um uh God
can't even think of a Will & Grace I was
trying to think what's the name of that
show I hate will it grace that was it
it's just it's odd to me that we we've
shifted from let's reboot everything to
let's bring it back with the same people
sure it's better but it's interesting as
far as general shifts in in approaches
go as their way of announcing the old
council of geeks the skits and sketches
are being revived no that's definitely
not happening even if some of the people
who were involved of that hadn't moved
away and we're local to me anymore i I
now better understand my own limits as
as a as a cinematographer and an editor
and and as that kind of writer and those
things for us such a pain to put
together like I'm proud of them and I'm
happy with them but like no I'm not
again do you think that's what the new
matrix will do oh yeah that's another
one because word is this is that the new
matrix is not a reboot but will be some
form of continuation so it's it's very
interesting about all these things that
we thought would be done are now being
brought back but not as a reboot now I
suppose for clarification because
somebody I just see as somebody's I can
see that somebody asked I can speak the
the difference between a reboot and what
I'm talking about a reboot is you clear
the continuity like you're you're
reusing the brand the iconography but
you're disregarding the previous films
as far as an actual story line in any
continuity goes so like the 2016
Ghostbusters was a reboot I forget when
the last Robocop was but that was a
reboot things like like the well the
ones I already meant
those are actually intended to tie back
to whatever was the previous iteration
he-man that's another one that got
announced recently that thing on Netflix
is apparently going to be a revival of
the show not like literally in the same
animation style they've got a new
animation house and everything but
continuity wise it is a is meant to be a
continuation so it's it's just really
interesting and actually part of what
got me thinking of it because I have now
already seen the Dark Crystal I burned
through it over the weekend I've already
shot my review that goes up on a Friday
and what the I immediately started
watching the making of as soon as I
finished and what was really interesting
is that one of the first things they
they had an interview with this guy
who's probably younger than I am it was
like some sort of creative executive
issue type over in Netflix and he had a
really I think a very healthy
perspective especially one when we've
seen so many of these reboots just not
work is that you know people when they
bring these things back they keep just
taking the name and thinking that people
will come back for the name they don't
come back to the name they come back for
the core things that they loved and if
you can bring back as many of those
things as possible that just makes more
sense and that was part of why Netflix
actually did Dark Crystal has puppies
again because it was actually pitched as
an animated series cuz the Henson
Company had kind of assumed no one's
ever gonna give us the money to do this
live-action puppetry ever again but
people like it maybe we'll get something
else but this is one guy and well I'm
sure there were other people but this
guy who they interview from the Netflix
was like you know really should be this
shouldn't it I mean I think it shows a
better understanding of what people want
when they want things to come back
because people don't have just an
attachment to a name or even a concept
it's not a brand people love specific
things and you should be bringing those
back whether you're doing it as a reboot
or a revival the marketers like reboots
that's the main thing
the thing is I'm not
marketers do love reboots I think
marketers hate reboots
I think the bookkeepers the accounting
and the risk assessment people love
reboots cuz I've said this repeatedly I
will continue to say it it's that the
something having a name that is already
known and worked at least once before is
considered to be a form of risk
avoidance so even if you have an idea
that is completely original if you can
crowbar a way to slap on a known name
that appeals more to the people who hold
the purse strings
because the chart says that it's more
likely to succeed if it's a name people
already know where sheera is a reboot
yes so the current sheera on Netflix is
a full and proper reboot the new he-man
will not be which does make it rather
unlikely that they're ever going to
connect with each other I for one am
ready AF for a Xena Warrior Princess
Royal
warrior princess reboot just saying I
don't think you need to reboot Xena
though have you seen Lucy Lawless she
looks amazing she could still totally
play that part there was no need to
reboot it you want to bring it back
bring it back is there any advice you
could give to me right now I have a
mixed bag this week my birthday on
Thursday but I don't think I couldn't
enjoy it much because I just put my pet
down oh well first of all I'm very sorry
to hear that Megan my heart goes out to
you I'm obviously I'm old enough and
I've had enough pets that I know what
it's like to to have to do that and it's
never fun and it's never it's never an
easy thing to go through I think you
know depending on you know what friends
you have around what things you can pull
together I think it will probably be in
your best interest to try and do
something because the alternative is to
be to send it home and wallow in your
loneliness now you know we don't know
each other personally enough for me to
make a solid recommendation but if you
have it in you to go out or at least
have people over my inclination is that
would be the better thing to do
but that's you know broadly speaking I
remember that one time the creators of
Swat cats did a Kickstarter for a pitch
for a reboot for that show oh god yeah I
didn't even think to talk about to bring
up Kickstarter and this how many
proposed revivals and reboots of things
like cartoons and video games and you
know spiritual successors this that and
the other because you know the people
running the campaign don't actually have
the rights to do the original thing how
many of those have launched how many of
them failed to even hit their thing and
then the ones that did how many of them
let us down oh boy there's an anime
series on Netflix called twelve forever
well have yet to see the series I've
been informed that the creator is being
outed for several sexual allegations I'm
you know I am neither familiar with the
show nor the behind the scenes thing so
I had absolutely no take on that cuz I
don't know anything about it it's
September why is it still 90 degrees
last year it was blazingly hot into
September to this unfortunately isn't
new I am sorry to say there's a xenia
reboot already it's called Ashe versus
the Evil Dead I only got a couple of
episodes into that I think I think I've
lost my e I think Ashley as a character
I've kind of grown out of not that like
he's suddenly batter like Bruce Campbell
can't still play him he still plays
imperfect I've just kind of grown out of
that type of character as being one who
I want to like stick around with for new
stuff it's fun for me to revisit the
older Evil Dead stuff cuz I have
nostalgia for that but I realize I don't
really want to see the continued
adventures of this character but that's
just me personally it seemed like a
really good continuation boss I'm Peter
Capaldi being in the Suicide Squad movie
I have none cuz I don't know who he's
playing he's in it he's an actor I like
I mean yay but I don't know who's
playing and I have to assume it's a
relatively small part given that
production is supposed to start up soon
if it was a major party would have been
cast long before this what is your least
favorite TV show how does anyone even
answer that
because I feel like to call something
your least-favorite you have to have
watched enough of it to really
understand why you dislike it most
things that I really dislike I'll say
that I just like them but I try not to
go off I'm eating grapes by the way I
try not to go off on them too much
because like I recognize that I haven't
watched much of them so there's only so
much I can judge let me if you want to
talk broadly about stuff that I just I
have a strong distaste for but like that
people around me seem to enjoy I
mentioned dwelling grace The Big Bang
Theory that's a that's a big one I
really really really don't like that
show but there are done a lot of
seedless grapes nope they're seen it I'm
just swallowing the seeds guess they're
seedless you know given that you know I
don't stick with shows that I don't like
for me to say something is my least
favorite show that'd be like watching
ten minutes of a two-hour movie going
that's my least favorite movies like
well you didn't stick with it but that's
not that's not me saying that you should
stick with the show you don't like if
you don't like it stop watching it but
you know are you eating grapes in quotes
see I'm amused by that cuz what would
grapes even be like I know what water is
but grapes now I'm really just curious
Gabe as to where your head's going let's
see
somehow grapes quotes is more concerning
than water yeah that's kind of what I'm
saying
ask my stupid question for the night
thanks folks yeah well done I just like
shows that other people are too
aggressive about thinking I should like
that can happen like when people who
like super hoods you you need to seize
you need to see this you need to see
this you need to see this and then
you're watching like that's it was okay
was fine but like you're a bit resentful
that people were so insistent that you
would love it yeah I've had that edibles
technology has really good I suppose
that's valid especially it like in
Vermont where I live edibles are
definitely like they're a thing now
they're not my thing but they're a thing
do you think they'll make a continuation
of the solo movies do you mean the Han
Solo Star Wars story thing no that thing
underperformed severely they're not
gonna build off that Thank You Carolyn
nicely caught I'm started watching the
filmography of French animation
filmmaker Michele Ocelot I did like I'm
not gonna try and properly say that with
accent from what I've seen his work as
incredible as a very strong sense of
style and storytelling do you know the
name of any of the things he's done
because I may or may not have seen some
of it odds are probably not just like
straight up I'll cop to that I'm that
way about Arrested Development yeah I
try to rest the development it was okay
I'm not my bag same with the office for
that matter like it's fine but like it's
okay
I guess a one reboot that has worked for
me recently is the new net Netflix
Sabrina surprised how hooked I am yeah I
haven't seen that then again I didn't
really watch the original either
have you read Ender's Game if so
thoughts I haven't at this point I'm
unlikely to just because you know I I
know enough about Orson Scott Card and I
mean here's what I would say I would
consider reading it if like somebody
sent a copy of the book to my P o box
but I am NOT going to pay money to
acquire a copy of the book not an audio
not anything else because I will not
give financial financially to that to
him I just I won't so I haven't read it
I feel like even if even if there wasn't
all that going on and like knowing about
him in general um I suspect I probably
missed the window to like
Ender's Game not to say that like I
wouldn't still get something out of it
but I really the impression I get is
that as a that is a book very much
geared towards somebody younger than me
like and if I'd read it in high school
or maybe even college I probably would
have gotten something out of it I feel
like I missed the window on that a bit
you don't like the office yeah me
neither
uh lost in space one day at a time one
day at a time I don't know the lost in
space reboot that was an odd thing I did
finish the first season of that I didn't
talk about it because like I didn't
watch it any time near to when it came
out that was a bit of an odd thing but
I'm not sure I'd watch another season of
it
um parker posey was great I'm like I'm
come to appreciate I really love well
done manipulative characters and because
it's it's very difficult to have a
character be manipulative in a way that
it
that it's clear to the audience that's
what's happening but also doesn't make
other carriages look dumb for giving in
and playing into those manipulations
that's very very tricky to do so when
it's done and when it's done well it is
a beautiful thing
oh yeah so Orson Scott Card he has he's
an out-and-out flat-out a homophobic
individual I mean like that's not much
like with Gareth Roberts being
transphobic me calling Orson Scott Card
homophobic is not a slur against him
that is very literally what he espouses
is the Houma flow the homophobic the
definition of homophobia so I believe
always see as a Mormon whether or not
even like I don't I neither condemn nor
do I give a pass based off someone's
religious backgrounds especially because
cuz to me your religion your spiritual
beliefs are very personal thing and what
things you do based off those are also
very personal but if you choose to make
that your public statement your publicly
known persona you make these positions
public I don't really care where they
come from I don't care if it's from his
religious background or if it was
something he was taught or if he had
some sort of traumatic experience with a
homosexual person I don't I'm not gonna
say I don't care I mean if something
traumatic happened to him you know my
heart goes out to anyone that that
happened to but where the homophobia
comes from is not what concerns me the
fact that it's there is what concerns me
so thoughts on the continuation of the
live-action Disney movies that's a thing
like the spin-offs like The Prince
Charming movie and prequel to Aladdin
called Dee Dee's I remember hearing
about genies I haven't heard anything on
that in years I assumed that was dead I
hadn't heard about the prince charming
thing I suspect because right now the
Maleficent sequel looks like it's gonna
open
very soft well actually quick show of
hands who remember that a secret sequel
- Maleficent comes out later this year
anybody anybody so like that is right
now trying to open very soft and I think
if that underperforms that that's
probably gonna almost immediately kill
off the idea of doing sequels to these
live-action reboots which I don't know
how I feel about that because as much as
I don't like the Disney live-action
remakes and I really don't
pardon me does think if they did sequels
to them you know they would have to do
something more interesting cuz they
wouldn't just be able to remake the
original I mean oh god they were really
just what they could remake the
direct-to-video sequels but I don't
think anyone actually believes that to
be a good idea Bueller Bueller
Oh God talk about a movie that I hate I
hate Ferris Bueller's Day Off can't
stand that movie like in all my friends
loved it and I'm sitting there watching
it they're laughing their butts off and
I'm sitting there going
he's the world's biggest entitled douche
why are why am I supposed to like this
the very idea that I should identify
with this guy feels insulting I really
hate that movie Return to Oz used to
terrify me no no that's legit return
return to Oz is creepy
I'm let's see third favorite new whose
story that's that's random I don't know
I don't know off the top my head I I
have no idea I don't even know how to
answer that I hate John Hughes movies
come to think of it The Breakfast Club
hold on I lost it The Breakfast Club is
one of the worst movies I've ever seen
see I do like The Breakfast Club
personally um I actually haven't seen
all that many of his movies but I do
like the Breakfast Club and I like
planes trains and automobiles
but I can't stand Ferris Bueller's Day
Off I'm I I couldn't even get through
trying to watch pretty-in-pink or
sixteen Candles but yeah his work was
very of a time his work was very 80s and
the thing is like I I feel like I'm
about at the I'm about the youngest kind
of age bracket people who were expected
to like that and I just didn't people
younger than me I don't I can't imagine
that they get very much out of it
thank you very much Thomas much
appreciated if you like fantasy check
out the chronicles of Prydain saw
someone else mention the book of three
but the whole series is very well
written
haven't heard of that one I'm very picky
with fantasy books largely just because
so many of them end up being epic
fantasy you know hero's journeys and I'm
just sick of it was why when I talked
about last week about the novel that I'm
trying to work on getting published for
next year is not an epic fantasy
it's a fantasy story but it doesn't deal
with you know prophecies and dark omens
and chosen ones that's like so many of
them deal in that and that's also saying
that some of them are very good because
some of them can still can be but I tell
ya I just I get really tired of that and
it's hard to find ones that don't deal
with those tropes even if they deal with
them well what would you do if a flying
muffin appeared eat it I'm back in class
now which is fine but I don't get why my
textbooks have to be so damned
overpriced because gutter going into
debt for the road for the next twenty
thirty years simply for the privilege of
being there is not enough money
apparently ah are you allowed to preview
what you think of Prisoner of Azkaban
it's both my favorite book and move
um yeah here's what I will preview for
that prisoner of azkaban is my favorite
book in the Harry Potter series
president of Azkaban is not my favorite
movie in the Harry Potter series and I
will be discussing why there is that
difference Monday next week
with that Anasta movie reference yes yes
it was uh I'm probably gonna watch ELF
bowling the movie for Christmas this
year just so I can riff on it what don't
bowling them I am legitimately terrified
to even ask alright alright you're gonna
pop over the discord real quick so just
as a reminder the discord is a patreon
exclusive and I do have a little channel
on there that it is for people to put in
questions for the livestream and I
guarantee that the ones put up on the
discord will be addressed here why do
you hate hellbent I've got multiple
rants on why I hate hell-bent and I'm
sure I'll talk about it again in the
future I don't have the energy right now
um well the first thing that was when I
was that doctor who did it first this
whole idea of reviving something but not
rebooting it that's actually kind of
true like 2005 the idea of reviving this
stuff is supposed to rebooting it wasn't
really a thing yet yeah doctor who did
exactly that now chorus doctor who's a
bit of a funny case because the nature
of the show and its history allowed you
to recast and basically do all the
things that you would do if you're just
gonna reboot it anyway
but still get away with tying in to the
old continuity so Doctor Who's a weird
exception to a lot of the normal things
that you have to do or avoid when doing
a revival of a show but it is kind it
did kind of kick things off
oh this was in reference to the to the
he-man show that's being worked on
I only hope Kevin Smith who's doing the
the new he-man takes a page from Noel
Stevenson's book and throws a bit of
subtext into he-man I have faith that he
won't have man in arms selling weed in
front of convenience stores but I worry
about his ability to add any real depth
to the property um
I mean not not to belittle Kevin Smith
but I think if you are expecting Shiraz
attention to theming and subtext and the
he-man reboot you may be expecting too
much but I expect he'll help put some
stuff in there you know some some little
things here and there to give it a
little bit more or at least I hope so
like give a smooth inject
I find it insulting how high on IMDb
hell-bent is let's see he'll been ruined
a perfectly I sent that go boy I said I
didn't want to talk hell-bent and like
now everyone's talking about it
ah okay I have not wrought rewatched
hell-bent in a very long time the very
first time I watched it I honestly
didn't even know what to think of it I
was just befuddled and confused by what
the heck it even was I didn't get it I
then revisited it a little bit later
after some folks sort of help me wrap my
head around what it was trying to be and
at the time I thought slightly better of
it cuz I at least knew what it was going
for but then after that my opinion of it
plummeted when I realized that while it
kind of did what it set out to do what
it is setting out to do is all stuff
that I fundamentally think were horrible
ideas
so that's your short and punchy version
on on hell-bent there's a lot of
specifics but like I said I do
I don't want this to become the then the
Fanueil gives himself an embolism
because he's ranting about hell-bent
livestream Kevin Smith said himself on
Batman Beyond that he won't do any of
his stereotypical things I mean I
wouldn't expect
I don't expect he would have I don't
think they brought on Kevin Smith you
know so that he could have Jason Mewes
voice or go like I don't think that
that's anybody's plan I think fear her
is worse
well here's the thing in trying to judge
whether or not an episode is worse than
hell-bent there's two different metrics
that you can measure that on either you
can measure it strictly on the episode
self-contained in which case no it's not
the worst episode of Doctor Who however
why it makes me so angry is because of
its impact on the show or overall its
impact on previous episodes its impact
on what it says about the doctor as a
character in the entire history of the
show and the things that it's saying
about his relationship with Clara visa
vie literally every other companion
relationship he's ever had I hate what
hell-bent does to Doctor Who as an as a
show much more than how good the episode
is is itself in a vacuum that's not the
issue
cuz in a vacuum yes there are absolutely
worse episodes than hell-bent but none
of them do damage beyond the the
one-hour takes to watch that episode
like hell-bent does
hell-bent in heaven-sent is a love
letter to pass companions no Adam I'm
gonna vehemently disagree with you help
bent is a love letter to Clara heaven
sent us a story about grief like I would
not consider either of those to be a
love letter to pass companions helping
is a love letter to one specific
companion and that's part of why I hate
it my Big Finish order just got here
squeeze that is definitely worth
screaming over Carolyn Big Finish like I
I've got more Big Finish than you just
start getting into I think in I don't
know two or three years or maybe I
finally caught up on classic I'll start
devoting more time to Big Finish man
it's good stuff though on the topic of
Kevin Smith your favorite of his movies
I'm like I haven't seen a lot of his
recent stuff I think the last one of his
I saw was red state and I didn't see
cop-out before that so of the ones he's
made um yeah Dogma I think have you
watched infinity train I tried I can't
or at least I can't legally and I don't
like to I don't torrent I don't pirate
cuz the thing is even though the Cartoon
Network app is free the way you log into
it is by giving your credentials for
whoever your cable provider is and I
don't have cable so I don't have a means
to legally C infinity train so now I
haven't seen it which is a shame because
I've seen it compared to over the garden
wall which I love and I'd like to see it
like I keep my eye out see if it gets a
DVD release cuz I've heard enough good
things that if I can find a decent price
I might blind buy it but there you go
how do I get into watching Torchwood nah
don't that's not everybody's me and some
people do genuinely like Torchwood
towards for what is such an uneven show
that I
I have a hard time recommending it just
as a thing have you seen the Steven
universe movie I haven't even seen the
Steven universe show so no I think
infinity train is on iTunes for purchase
I haven't tried watching it that way
myself
see it excuse me if I'm gonna shell out
the money to buy something I want
physical media I don't like buying
digital unless there's literally no
other way for me to get it I'm just I'm
slightly I'm slightly stubborn and show
and show my age a little bit and that
way but like if I want to own it in a
for want to pay money to own it I want a
physical disk
I really do put my foot down and draw a
line in the sand over that let's see and
then a world like the culture of the
Federation would there's still be a need
for gay bars okay so this is a question
so the Federation will be Star Trek the
culture would be from the Iain M banks
books he has a whole series of them so
probably not because in a in a more
utopian egalitarian culture where
sexuality or in the case of the culture
even gender itself is just not something
that has a lot of morality attached to
it either way I would think the need for
something like a gay bar would not they
may not go away entirely but I can't
imagine it would be the same sort of
thing where you go there to ensure that
who you encounter are people who approve
of you because if society is a whole
approved of you then like if you were
say a gay man if you were tracked to
someone you could just say hey I'm
attracted to you or you go oh no
actually I that's that's not where my
tricep oh okay cool like if we were a
truly egalitarian everyone was still
think you could have that interaction to
be okay but you know we're not there yet
therefore we do still need you know gay
spaces those bean spaces etc etc etc so
in a culture that just doesn't have
those hang-ups I wouldn't imagine
be much need for those with something
like the Federation since it's born out
of Earth I mean I suppose there there
could be just uh it's just hung on as a
cultural staple but that's you know that
will be speculative yay someone else who
wants physical media yeah how should I
deal with my extremist and T LGBTQ
mother ah I don't know because I I'm
incredibly fortunate in that the people
who matter the most to me in my life
none of them have faded out of my life
or pushed me away or been unaccepting of
Who I am even as Who I am has continued
to change in a ball because part of this
thing is that like it's not you know
when I when I first came out to my
mother it was about a decade ago and it
was just as a crossdresser you know the
whole lot I didn't even know that gender
fluid was a word much less a concept
that I understood so you know I haven't
I don't have first-hand experience in
dealing with people who are important to
your life you know enough where I
presume at least you don't just want to
cut them out I don't have experience in
dealing with toxic people who you you
want to still have in your life for one
reason or another and as a result I'm
rather unqualified to say we should do
the it's just hard when you don't have
support and I don't know I don't know
your living situation I don't know if
you're still living at home where you
actually have to see her on a daily
basis if you're only seeing her on
occasion I don't know actually what
would necessarily make that easier or
harder because you know there's an
argument to be made that her just being
immersed in
you know you being you would help break
down the wall a little bit but then you
know if she was seeing you on a daily
basis that's a daily opportunity for her
to erode your sense of self if that's
something she's actively doing so I
honestly honestly just don't know I
would honestly say if you have the
ability to reach out to a therapist or a
counselor of any sort to do that
somebody with some sort of credentials
some qualification because you know that
that is far enough outside of my own
personal sphere of experience that I
don't I wish I had more to offer but I
don't I do wish you'd absolutely the
best of luck though I may be being silly
here but is it true that the trickster
created at the time bug from turn left
yes yeah they actually say that in in
turn left that the time bug is one of
the tricksters brigade so yeah that is
in there jumping on back to Doctor Who
as we usually do you fall to eventually
I live with my parents I'm an adult but
I have autism and my parents have
guardianship of me um when the person
who's not accepting of you has some
degree of control over you whether it's
a guardianship or it's because you're
not an adult yet that massively
complicates everything
and again the the best that I can offer
to do is to see if you can get some sort
of therapy or counseling you know for to
talk about your relationship with your
mother not like conversion therapy or
any of that crap but someone who might
have some suggestions or might be
willing to sit down and talk with both
you and your
they're together in a professional
controlled setting I need to know more
about your areas that look pretty but I
can't identify what's on them okay so
let me see if I can tip it the right way
it's that way so these are Slytherin
earrings and there would my partner Liz
gave me these friend of hers actually
actually makes them I also have some
wood TARDIS's made by the same person
what do you think about the straight
pride thing any possible argument that
it is not meant to be anti LGBTQ was
immediately stomped by the fact that
they tried to have it happen during
Pride Month you are literally trying to
stomp on lgbtq+ people and I have no
interest in even having a conversation
about her with those people they can
piss off is it weird that whenever I
hear you talk about lgbtq+ advice it's
always comforting and warm I don't know
if it's weird but now you made me feel
warm reading that so thank you
I'm gonna be a slither in this Halloween
awesome um I'm gonna slow they're in
every day so you know Halloween works
too I would like to see a Clara and Aria
a kami Maisie Maisie book amazing
Williams said I don't know why I'm flaky
on names take character and Doctor Who
um I wouldn't cuz I just don't know how
you how it would differentiate itself
from Doctor Who as a show cuz they've
basically got their own hardest they
would be doing the same thing I I don't
know
Captain Jack costume is in the works for
me ooh nice choice I was looking forward
to your LGBT content that's nice to hear
and actually like this was a slightly
weird month because the video I put out
that kind of touched on it wasn't about
it openly and that was the one about
joke-telling from from a couple of days
ago so you know that was uh that I was
actually surprised that that that one
went down as well as it did to be honest
I I thought it was gonna be a much more
contentious video but how about that
that went pretty well
pre discovery Star Trek was surprisingly
bad about LG BT issues like I even
though I do like Star Trek
I'm not immersed enough in it to know so
so when you say it's bad like I know
there was like basically zero
representation going on within the show
which for the world that was supposedly
said it doesn't make a lot of sense um
but like were they actually bad about it
in that like they had negative
representation cuz to my memory I never
saw anything like that um that's not to
say it isn't there like I said I haven't
seen everything of Star Trek like there
isn't even any iteration of Star Trek
that I've seen every episode of so I
don't know if that that is or isn't
case the LGBT content was how I found
you then was excited for all the Doctor
Who I mean that those two things are the
main way that people find me either
through the lgbtq+ content or through
Doctor Who Doctor Who obviously the
thing I talk about the most but the
lgbtq+ content is also stuff that I make
a point of doing regularly so you know
they it keeps coming up whereas other
stuff that I talk about you know I'll
talk about Star Wars and I'll talk about
you know the MCU but that's when it's
topical I'll talk about lgbtq+ at least
once a month of regardless what exactly
is negative representation oh boy
there's a can of worms I'm I'm gonna
slightly dodge that question because I
can't think of like a great example off
the top of my head but what I would mean
is in in the context of something like
Star Trek which was what I was saying
supposedly it is a post need utopian
society Star Trek is so in theory there
is proper quality so if at any point
they they did a story that depicted
within the Federation that there was
still bias or prejudice or confusion or
whatever about any part of the lgbtq+
spectrum within specifically within the
context of that show given what its
premises I would consider that to be
negative because it's taking a stance
against a certain kind of people that is
it and in fact in direct violation of
the stated premise of the show so within
the specific context of Star Trek that
is how I would say it is there how
something is or is a negative
representation is actually very much a
case-by-case basis just like a positive
representation is a case-by-case basis
and you can't just make the blanket
thing well if you do this it's always
good if you do this it's always bad gay
bookstores need to be a thing um
depending on where you do your shopping
they kind of are in some places
although they may not be what you think
I have an odd dilemma what do I do when
I have creative ideas for short films
and art projects but I absolutely have
no desire for praise or recognition just
do them
I mean I'd honestly I would think that
would free you up immensely because if
you don't care if people like it or if
that many people even see it then just
do it just do whatever you want to do um
me you know I do care so um that's
that's not a headspace second I can get
into yeah but I need the gate hang out
that isn't clubs or bars cuz they're a
bit much for me since I'm autistic
oh good fair a lot of the well
particularly the gay male but like in
general a lot of the LGBTQ plus social
scene is very much built around the
nightlife which you know if you're
someone who doesn't like naturally
gravitate towards going out to clubs or
parties or be up late or big groups of
people then I can leave you feeling a
little isolated and that is kind of a
kind of was it a sexual cafes somebody
give me investors on the phone will make
a mint off this it'll be great I watched
an anime last year from I'm an anime
film from last year called penguin
highway okay and as fantastic characters
a surreal yet cleverly touching sir
who's wonderful animation huh I hadn't
heard of that one um like made me think
of penguin island which is a book that I
also have a read but I've heard about no
no I hadn't I hadn't heard about that
one
I see here is the Terrance dicks tribute
already shot or is that later because
you want to script and play more so k9
knows this because this I put out I put
up the docket for what's planned for the
rest of the month up on the patreon I
have plugged it twice I don't know if
that just makes me a bigger shill or
getting better at this but um Sunday's
video is going to be a tribute to
Terrance dicks who passed away last week
and if you don't know who he is watch
the video on Sunday and if you like
Doctor Who at all you'll realize why you
should appreciate who he is but um I
have already shot it um I didn't script
it I did however you know sort of be
sure I have my ducks in a row in terms
of double-checking you know what things
he had worked on and exactly you know
and I watched a number of interviews
with him and like I did I did I did
something I almost never do I did
research cool before I shot that but no
I did I didn't script that one so it is
already shot if you have to choose a
doctor from new who to completely scrap
who would it be oh I don't like that
question um all right first things first
Whitaker I'm not gonna allow to be part
of this discussion because she's only at
her first series and until she's done
her ten year I don't feel like I have
any business saying whether or not she
should be scrapped so she's off the
table that leaves us well it leaves us
for technically five if you want to
count the war doctor but that also seems
like a gimme and he'd be the easy call
to remove so I'm not gonna count him
either let's make it actually difficult
so if I'm scrapping one doctor out of
those who have completed their run
meaning Eccleston Smith Tennant
Capaldi huh uh I I would ditch tenon
don't hurt me it's not to say I want to
ditch tenon
I love done and stuff but if you're
gonna make me pick from those for who to
get rid of that's sorry
don't don't hit me nice nails thank you
this actually huh I tweeted about this
but I've been saying for months now that
eventually the day was going to come
when I was not gonna give enough of a
crap to put in the effort to take my
nail polish off before going into the
office for the start of a work week
because I had yesterday off cuz it was
Labor Day market calendars today is the
day rye whatever craps I had left that
were motivating me to take my nail
polish off before going to work they are
gone Wow flips table how dare you tenant
is perfect I'm surprised only one
person's flip at a table can't say
nothing it was not honest yeah to my own
detriment I think tenon is why I got
into Doctor Who
again like please realize the context of
that question but I I do liked and and
not as much as a lot of people but I do
like him if I wasn't in the food
business I would do my nails I love
doing my nails oh my god I've hated
taking this stuff off and yeah
apparently I've run out of craps so
there we go
you've poked the bear and a poke the
bear I think I think I've set up camp in
its cave I'm gonna censor this slightly
just because I don't want the the
archive of this to get to monetize do
you have a single F
left when he comes to that job I've got
a couple not many though I think I think
what it is is that I I've run out of the
energy I've run out of the the craps
that I would need to put energy into
appearing more traditionally masculine
because the thing is I used to to go to
work I used to put my hair up in the Hat
the way that I still do a fair number of
the videos here I did that every day for
about a year and a half from when I
first got my hair colored that stuffed
it up in the cab I think everybody
probably heat I did for so long I think
everyone probably thought I was trying
to cover the fact that was going bald
which I'm not but I did that but that
was work that was effort to get out
stick it up and make sure it stayed up
there
I had sick of doing it so I stopped and
liked the nails it would have been work
and effort for me to take this off and a
stop like there's more that I could do
to like truly not give a crap but like
that would be the scale tipping in the
other direction so like right now it's
that like it's it's properly flat it's
at a true neutral um I just
I'm not putting I'm not putting extra
effort you know beyond simply looking
professional you know because I still go
you know decent you know nice pants but
now shirt I look professional in the
office because none of this is against
dress code so you know I'll do that
because that's an actual requirement of
my job but if it's not actually required
for my job I'm done putting an effort to
appear the way that I think my
co-workers would prefer to have me
appear but by the same token I'm not
gonna put in extra effort to go the
other way and really push the boundaries
because to go in you know with lipstick
and eyeshadow or or heels that's also
more work
and again I don't give enough of a crap
to put in the effort to make it look
like I give even less of a crap than I
currently do so there you go I mean look
I say all this like I still do my job I
don't want to give the impression that I
like go in and sit there and don't do
anything I do my job
I think I'm halfway decent at it which
is one of the things that's frustrating
it would almost be easier if I sucked at
it but the reason I've had this job for
eight years is cuz I'm actually pretty
good at it which you know that's its own
weird thing my favorite movie from the
1980s is Amadeus that movie is a
masterpiece on all fronts that is a
really really good movie
yeah just across the boards it's
phenomenal mm-hmm do any of your
co-workers watch this channel not
actively I don't think I do think I have
at least one who is who has seen a few
cuz actually she asked me today and is
the first time it's having at work she
asked me today what my preferred
pronouns were and I actually said to her
you know you're the first person to ask
that um it's kind of nice I told I told
her what I tell everyone I don't care
but I did point out that like everybody
in the office is gonna know me as he's
so like she might as well stick with
that otherwise no one's gonna know what
the heck she's talking about um but that
was good that was kind of an odd thing
um forgive me if this is out of line but
is your partner non-binary you
consistently use neutral terms no she's
not by not non-binary I and I don't use
neutral terms I refer to Liz's she I
always refer to her as she but what
there's a reason I use partner instead
of girlfriend cuz to me girlfriend feels
like high school and what I have with
her is more substantive than that she is
a partner in my life and partner feels
good and right and correct for us but it
partner is also a bit of a euphemistic
term and it's something that often
people use to you know cover that
they're in a saying engender
relationship or to not specifically
gender they're you know whoever their
partner is so like my use of the term
partner is not to hide Liz's gender
because she's not 9 bar non-binary she
is a sis woman she's bisexual but she's
not non-binary and it's okay for me to
say that because like we've had this
discussion with her along the channels
you know she was in my video on bisexual
representation so I'm not like outing
her by saying bad you know this is this
is all known what's on your mousepad
that is a Borderlands 2 mousepad I think
that's zero if I remember I haven't
played Borderlands 2 in ages and I can't
remember hideout that mm-hmm thanks for
a great livestream everyone thanks for
stopping in Meg was good to see you oh
crap that's been going for a while I
gotta I gotta jump back to the discord
real quick ah okay so let's see I'm back
on the discord now for these I know this
perhaps a little outside of what you're
thinking but I'd like to see a revival
of the United States of Tara
oh that would be interesting partly
because that show ended abruptly and
weirdly the last half of the third
season it kind of goes off the rails a
bit but it was a really fascinating show
up to that point if folks have never
seen it was a show on Showtime about
someone with D ID to suppose DISA so D
disassociative disassociative identity
disorder colloquially known as multiple
personality disorder um and it was very
good and very well acted like as it kind
of went off the rails second half of its
third season and that also ended up
being the last season I wouldn't be
interested in seeing a continuation on
that just so we can maybe get a better
ending um also thundercats is a
live-action movie do you think if doctor
who gets asked and then axed in the next
few years that it will come back 20
years later if it does what will we call
it it would be the newest so new who
would make sense but what would that
make our current Doctor Who okay if
doctor who ever goes away again I think
it is always gonna be a possibility that
it can be brought back I think the very
nature of the revival of the 2005
revival for the coronary
doctor who were in shows that this show
can't be brought back at a later date
basically without missing a beat so I
would absolutely expect that to happen
um whoa boy what would we call it I mean
I don't know maybe maybe we'd end up
calling the car series the Millennial
era I mean it extends a bit beyond just
the millennial decade but that was when
it started so maybe that would be it and
then whatever we would be knew he knew
who or knew knew who could be like new
New York or new new new new new new new
new new new new who let's see-oh
thoughts on the idea of the Buffy reboot
I actually from what I know about what
they're approaching I think the Buffy
reboot has a lot of potential especially
with the fact that they're talking about
having an african-american Buffy because
on the one hand that could be very it's
always execute independent and it could
be very gimmicky and shallow and dumb
but I think if you're gonna reboot Buffy
um the thing to do is to brain is to put
it back in high school again and have it
reflect a high school experience this
that would be distinctly different from
that of Michelle Gellar's Sarah Michelle
Gellar's Buffy Summers
so if they have Buffy be
african-american and reflect what what
the high school experience of an
african-american in it now is it has the
potential to still keep that core idea
of the problems of high school blown up
- Horror Story proportions but to
reflect a different age you know in
terms of like now a different time
period and a different high school
experience from a distinctly different
perspective because of who she is
I think there's honestly a ton of
potential in that again a lot of
potential for it's a completely belly
flop and it's always gonna be execution
independent but honestly I don't think
that's a bad idea at all
I have still to this day never seen an
episode of Buffy I mean so it's sort of
like what I said with me and not having
read Ender's Game when I was younger
depending on how old you are now I mean
you might be outside the window of
appreciating it you know depending on
your own preferences and tastes I do
think it's something best enjoyed by
people who are young adults or becoming
young adults because that's the
experience that it speaks to that's not
to say that you can't be able to the
than that and still enjoy it I'm just
saying that's who it's geared towards
and if you're outside that demographic I
you may not get as much out of it it's
hard to say I'm getting into D&D
whoo-hoo I'm not ashamed of it nor am I
scared of being a newbie around
professionals D&D is great I like I
would love to play more D&D I haven't
played in a couple years now but ya know
you're never too old to get into D&D
dandies awesome especially if you can
get with a good reliable gaming group oh
it's so good
new new new whoo so good they named it
thrice excuse me
Buffy is pretty timeless in in my
opinion it's pretty timeless too if your
high school experience reflects a 90s
white middle-class high school
experience I mean I think there is a lot
of space to open that up and it's it's
not as dated as you would think because
it likes so much of it it's just dealing
on fantastical rules anyway it doesn't
date as badly as something like Adam I
don't know nine oh two one oh which also
had a revival hey bringing back the
original theme that they didn't stick
around for very long did it
so it's certainly aged better than a lot
of stuff set in high schools in general
um because there aren't as many aro
specific references as you would expect
or at least not that are important so no
it's it's it's aged better than a lot of
stuff from the same timeline I'll
definitely grant that
so is this about any revived franchise
can we suggest good bad revive stuff
I mean drop in suggestions I'm probably
gonna be ending the the livestream soon
and as I said we went all over the place
and I died that theme didn't stick long
I don't know how to control the
conversation I'm very bad at it can we
appreciate the cheese man from Buffy I
wear the cheese that cheese does not
wear me how are the newfound Let's Plays
doing in terms of views etc um well I
mean luck you can see for yourself the
view counts up there it's the lowest
viewed stuff I've put out in a while um
that said I am gonna finish it out how
if if I have as much left in the game as
I think I have I'll get two more Let's
Plays out of it and I'll have gotten
through the whole thing but yeah it's
not uh it's not particularly well viewed
now to be fair at least to my
understanding of Let's Plays generally
they they go better when it's you know
either
games that are brand new or are very
much sort of in the zeitgeist cuz I'm
like I'm never gonna start lets playing
or you know stream me something like
fortnight or whatever cuz not it's not
my bag and and and all of that but like
unless you really tap into something
that is super popular or remain so
generally live streams do well by being
on current recently released up which
this game while out this year you know
it's a small indie 16-bit style game on
Steam from months ago so I'm not
surprised that the that the less plays
aren't getting a ton of traction but I'm
still enjoying doing them and like I
said I'm can I consider doing others in
the future but you know depending on
what what sort of games I actually lined
up I have a couple of ideas of what I
might do but like I wouldn't I wouldn't
expect like the less plays to like
suddenly become a regularly scheduled
feature but you know it might be
something that I'll revisit again down
the line doctor
ah the Rocko's Modern Life movie was
good that's another recent revival it's
been a good month for animated movies
Rocco Zim Steven universe I haven't seen
the invader zim one well I also haven't
seen the Steven universe but I haven't
seen Steven universe the show um I
should watch the invaders m1 because I
have seen all of that show um I feel I
feel like I might have grown out of it a
bit have you played life is strange I
have not like most up-to-date console
have got up there's a ps3 and I didn't
have a steam account until I got
newfound courage which I I only got
because the and I mentioned this in the
first livestream that the that the guy
who who was the the director behind it
the main designer sent me a steam key on
it cuz he wanted me to play it so you
know my I I keep up with gaming in terms
of like what's going on in general but I
haven't played like the last game but I
I bought and played through and actually
really enjoyed was Bastion which is what
2012 that game it's great if you've
never played it it's phenomenal I loved
it but like I'm cheap you know and games
cost 60 bucks before I even get into
microtransaction stop what are your
thoughts on Dark Crystal Ages of
resistance review up Friday short
version do you watch Doctor Who on BBC
America prime or DVD I mean like I I the
series on DVD well I just blu-ray at
this point because I'd like having
physical media like but mainly I'm I've
been getting it through prime lately I
know it's it's moving off prime soon so
I have to figure out I'm gonna keep up
with it I'll deal with that later
cards against humanity' rules I haven't
played it in a while actually I mean
I've got the box up there a dude what
the haps I now feel very unhip for even
having read that out loud
halo must be the best sci-fi game
franchise see shooters aren't really my
bag like as about as close as I come to
shooters would be something like
Uncharted I mean I've never seriously
enjoyed shooters as a genre I think like
about as much as I ever loved it was
gold and I back in the day but that that
was pretty specific do you ever fear
would feel weighed down by the hard
copies you must home I don't own as many
hard copies as much physical media as
you might think I mean I do have like
basically a wall of DVDs but it's not as
much as you might think cuz I've
actually gotten pretty good about
culling it and going back and going
alright if I'm honest with myself am I
actually ever gonna watch that one again
or do I just have it because I feel like
I'm supposed to or I thought I was gonna
watch it more and I haven't and I've got
I've done that a number of times and
I've managed to take basically keep it
from getting bigger so like stuff goes
out new stuff comes in so I've got I've
also gotten much better about only
getting stuff that I really want I used
to have a bit more of a completionist
mentality like I think first time I I
finally started to break that was when I
bought on DVD cuz I do actually like
Revenge of the Sith but there was part
of me that was like well you have to
also get episode 1 and episode 2 and it
took a lot to make myself like no no I
don't I don't have to I don't have to be
a completionist on this and I I was able
to break that so I I I'm Way more
selective at this point about buying
sets that you know DVDs release
that I actually want that I truly
believe that I will watch again not
because I'm supposed to have it so like
I've already got the first five seasons
of Game of Thrones on blu-ray I intend
to buy season six you know if I ever see
it for sale I'm not gonna buy season
seven or eight because I you know season
seven had a couple of good moments but
so much of it was just building towards
season eight which I didn't like so but
I'll keep my seasons one through six
because I already watched those looks
like we have some fun form of DLCs for
movies now theatrical releases with
extended and altered versions are all
the rage now well I mean like the
director's cut is not a new thing I I'm
not a huge fan of them in general
especially when they appear to supersede
the theatrical cut like I'd like and
this is not a new opinion this is one
I've had for a while like I remember so
a movie that I quite like is the 90
something or other 90s last of the
mohicans the one with Daniel day-lewis
that's a good thing I like it because
I'm actually named after the main
character from the book so you know that
works out well um but the thing is I
I bought it twice on 2d on DVD on two
different times one time where it said
director's cut another time where it
didn't say director's cut but it was
still the director's cut and I got rid
of both of them because the and and I
can't find the theatrical cut of that
movie and the director's cut the
director's cut the ending completely
kills the pacing it completely loses
steam because there's this long
protracted monologue from from
Chingachgook at the end and the
theatrical release it's short and punchy
and makes the point and sustains the the
power of what happened in the lead-up to
it
and then the director's cut it just
completely loses steam because you won't
shut up and I don't like the director's
cut I can't find the theatrical it
drives me completely off the wall so
like my like some people are like the
directors good is the ultimate version
like I got disillusioned on that like 15
years ago any advice on how to limit
hard copies besides the Khan harpy
method I mean I haven't bought in a
while I just borrow I mean like just
like I say try to let try to be honest
with yourself will you ever actually
watch that again I try to be on it or
are you just buying it because you liked
it in the because that was another thing
I used to just buy oh I like that in the
theater I'll buy that and then it would
sit on the shelf and I realized I
actually don't have a massive urge to
plug it in and watch it again
and just sort of learning myself over
time I am well over at this point
I'm gonna pop back to the discord real
quick um I wish the Sabrina reboot have
been more similar to the original run I
didn't really watch either so don't have
an opinion on that do you think a reboot
reboot could work see I didn't really
watch reboot I knew it was a thing I
remember like catching bits of it but I
never really watched that either what do
you prefer when something is rebooted or
if it's brought back as a revival I do
think that is really a case-by-case
situation because sometimes like for
whatever reason maybe given how old the
thing is you can't do anything other
than reboot it but I find the revival
trend to be really interesting because
it requires way more thought because you
have to figure out how does this
continue from what it was before where
is reboot there are good reboots out
there but you can do a very lazy reboot
you just go okay well we take the name
and a couple of elements and just do
whatever we want whereas if you're gonna
do a revival you kind of have to be more
careful about how you're gonna do it
that's not to say they always succeed
but I kind of appreciate them for that
alone if nothing else if a movie is
pretty much good on its own but ends up
being remade due to quote-unquote
popular opinion and the remake flops do
you think it now will affect the
original movie well no
bad remake especially if the remake
flops doesn't take the original at all
if anything it makes you appreciate the
original more because you're like boy
that thing was really great not like
that new thing that happened I think
we're where things get weird is when
some is one a remake is doing something
distinctly different from the original
but it's also extremely successful to
the point that it overshadows the
original like Scarface is a great
example of that
like I don't even know how many people
realize that the Al Pacino Scarface
movie is a remake at all cuz it's
completely overshadowed the original and
it's very very different in terms of the
specifics but you know it's it's an odd
thing that happens sometimes I'm just
I'm just trying to burn through the
discord guy so so bare with folks
I still say guys sometimes cuz in my
head guys is a gender-neutral term I'm
still trying to get out of that habit
[Music]
let's see do you think some Disney
movies need a reboot like the black
culture brides Black Cauldron is about
the one Disney animated film that I
would have no problem with them remaking
cuz there's a source material for them
to go off of and they could probably use
another bite at the Apple cuz Black
Cauldron was not good and I would rather
that they really that they try and
remake bad things or things that didn't
quite work rather than take something
that was good and try and capture
lightning in a bottle again I'm not
related to the topic but were you
annoyed and stranger things by the fact
that of the four main guys the only one
who was single by the end was implied to
be asexual
um no I I mean it didn't really occur to
me so no I didn't know and any it
finally this last one off the discord
any tips for camping writing without me
completely dumb not really because uh
camp is not really my thing I don't
really I'm not big on camp II so I'm not
a person to ask like I can appreciate it
when it works but I dislike it more
often than I like it so I'm not a person
to ask for an opinion on how to make
camp work
oh okay oh so I could have saved this
more clearly I was talking about
Avengers endgame the spider-man far from
home mid-summer getting a theatrical
release a weeks after the original run
that's a weird thing that they're doing
now I I would be curious to see what the
returns on these are I can't imagine
that they're all that much but like the
it's basically I think they're really
only it's not like a proper full
rerelease they do that like kind of at
the tail end of the of the things normal
theatrical lifespan so I think they're
just extending the normal theatrical
lifespan of these movies a bit by doing
that it's a weird thing I don't really
think too much of it either way beyond
that I used to think of guys as a
gender-neutral term but some people
identify as female don't like to be used
with them I think that's fine yeah I'd
like like I said it's in my head calling
a group of people guys is a
gender-neutral term but like I also know
that that's not everyone's understanding
so I try to get its but it's very
ingrained in my head I've been saying
that for decades so I'm still trying to
get out of the habit it's my default and
I have to force myself to not use it oh
I think I my back is starting to be
annoyed with me for being in this chair
so I think I need to wrap it up plus I'm
also over time have you seen the Dark
Crystal series I have review Friday
should [ __ ] be a gender-neutral term as
far as I personally am concerned it is a
gender-neutral term I actually call way
more Mayo identifying people I not it's
not a word I use often but like I've
called more male identifying people that
word then I have female identifying
people again though that's just me like
I I'm not gonna say how other people
should or shouldn't use the word
personally I don't assign gender to
that word personally come out of water I
am about 17 minutes past when they
should have ended so I'm gonna wrap it
up there thanks everybody for joining me
we had a pretty good turnout for this
one especially because Harry I couldn't
stay on the stated topic of the stream
worth like darn but nice for everyone to
stop in all the same much appreciated
one of the worst games came out last
year was the fan made half like game
hunt down the freeman yeah I heard about
that I dare you to play it no because
I'd have to pay for it and no but that's
it folks thanks for joining me I hope
folks had a good Labor Day weekend and
if you come from an area that doesn't
recognize Labor Day oh you just had a
good weekend
hope you have a good rest of the week
and thank you for everything thank you
for the support for the super chats the
patreon watching sharing liking just
being around it it really does just sort
of brighten up stuff to know that people
care about what I do so thanks again
everybody for joining me and I want you
all to remember that you are beautiful
you're loved
you are valid you are the council I'm
just running the meetings have a good
night